am dienstag findet ein spatenstich statt
in der van swieten kaserne in wien der
basis des sanitäts zentrums ost wird die
stellungs kommission wien neu errichtet
ein wichtiger schritt für
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
den investitionen in das bundesheer
werden mehr und nicht weniger wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass das budget des
österreichischen bundesheeres steigt wir
haben das drei mal erreicht mit einer
steigerung des regel budgets aber ganz
offen gesprochen es ist so vieles an
zusätzlichen noch notwendig diese
investitionsrückstand soll nun schritt
für schritt abgebaut werden und dass wie
im fall dieses neubaus auch durchaus mit
erhöhtem tempo in nur 18 monaten also
ende 20 23 soll die neue stellungs
kommission wien fertig sein
sowohl was die investitionen anbelangt
was
durch die direkte verbindung erhofft
sich tanner auch organisatorische
synergien zwischen der stellungs
kommission und dem er ins spital